en este vídeo vamos a hablar sobre cómo
pueden regularse las poblaciones y de
forma general podemos hablar de esta
regulación de población en dos
categorías diferentes la regulación que
depende de la densidad de la población y
la regulación que es independiente de la
densidad de la población primero
hablemos de la regulación que depende de
la densidad de la población permítanme
dibujar una pequeña gráfica que nos
ayude a visualizar esto en el eje
vertical tenemos a la población
y en el eje horizontal tenemos el tiempo
t en vídeos anteriores hablamos de la
población también particular me gusta
usar de ejemplo a los conejos y de cómo
crecen exponencialmente si crece cierto
porcentaje cada mes esta población
crecerá exponencialmente pero no podemos
esperar que esto ocurra por siempre si
los conejos crecieran exponencialmente
si no se encontraran limitados por nada
pronto cubriría en la superficie de la
tierra y después llenaría en el universo
pero sabemos que hay cosas que limitan
su crecimiento
sabemos que el medio ambiente tiene
cierta capacidad de cargar
en un momento hablaremos con mayor
detalle sobre esta capacidad de carga y
qué es lo que la determina conforme
aumenta la densidad de población de
conejos en cierta región comenzarán a
actuar los factores de regulación de
población que dependen de la densidad y
estos factores son limitantes y cuáles
son algunos de los factores de
regulación de población que evitan que
una población crezca más allá de los
límites de carga del medio ambiente uno
de los factores más obvios es el de
competir por los recursos uno de los
recursos más obvios es el alimento esta
es una fotografía de australia a
mediados de 1800 cuando tuvieron un
problema de sobrepoblación de conejos
al principio llevaron algunos conejos
para poder cazar los pero estos se
reprodujeron como conejos y se estimó
que en ciertos momentos llegaron a ser
más de mil millones de conejos que
poblaron al país quizá esto les parezca
tierno pero se volvió un enorme problema
ya que los conejos se comían todas las
cosechas y también se comieran el pasto
que era el alimento para el ganado así
que tuvieron una tremenda infestación de
conejos
pueden imaginarse uno de los recursos
por el que competían era el pasto en la
imagen pueden ver que el suelo no tiene
nada de pasto ni vegetación y es muy
probable que los conejos se hayan comido
toda la vegetación del lugar así que un
tipo de recurso por el que se compite es
el alimento otro tipo de recurso podría
ser el agua ya que sólo existe el agua
suficiente para cierta cantidad de
organismos y aunque a menudo hablamos de
animales esto también aplica a plantas a
bacterias y a todo tipo de organismos y
si hablamos de plantas u otros recursos
sería la luz pues es algo que limita la
cantidad de plantas que pueden existir
en cierta área también la limita la
cantidad de agua disponible y la
cantidad de nutrientes en el suelo quizá
hayan visto imágenes de selvas
tropicales con dosel muy denso en donde
las plantas buscan cualquier brecha en
el dosel para tener acceso a la luz
hay otros ejemplos de recursos que no
aplican a las plantas necesariamente uno
de ellos es la idea del refugio la cual
aplica a los humanos y a otro tipo de
animales que necesitan de refugios para
esconderse o de un lugar para
reproducirse así pues cuando aumenta
demasiado la densidad de población en
cierta región estas cosas van a comenzar
a limitar esta densidad y nos va a
llevar a esta curva logística que vimos
en un vídeo anterior en la cual vemos
que comienza a acercarse a la capacidad
de carga y es posible que esta curva
llegue más allá de la capacidad de carga
lo cual genera una situación inestable y
después caiga por debajo del nivel de
esta capacidad de carga y luego ocurra
algo que la haga subir y después la haga
bajar quedando algo así que otros
factores hay que dependan de la densidad
otro factor serían los depredadores
cuando hay más conejos es más fácil
atrapar a alguno y así conseguir la cena
así que está el factor de la depredación
una vez que la población ha crecido lo
suficiente
es cuando llegan los depredadores
buscando conseguir una cena fácil otra
cosa que no es tan obvia es que cuando
tenemos una población muy densa existe
un mayor contacto o interacción entre
los organismos y las enfermedades y
parásitos se transmiten más fácilmente y
van a limitar el tamaño de la población
hemos visto muchos ejemplos de esto en
la historia cuando han ocurrido
epidemias esto también limita la
cantidad de población que puede existir
un ejemplo que siempre me viene a la
mente es la peste en tiempos medievales
donde el contagio era muy fácil entre
una persona y otra o incluso entre las
ratas y las personas otro factor que
está relacionado con todo esto es la
acumulación de desechos
si tenemos una población de alta
densidad y los desechos se encuentran
por doquier esta puede contaminar al
agua oa las fuentes de alimento lo que
ayuda a la propagación de parásitos y
enfermedades todos estos factores ayudan
a delimitar qué tan densa puede ser una
población y la capacidad de carga en
cierta región quizá ustedes pueden decir
que los individuos de una población
pueden buscar nuevas regiones en donde
vivir y es algo que ha ocurrido con
muchas especies un ejemplo famoso son
los lemmings que cuando su población
llega a ser muy numerosa grupos de ellos
se marchan a buscar nuevos lugares en
donde vivir a veces llegan a lugares que
no son muy buenos para ellos así pues
todos estos son factores que dependen de
la densidad y podemos pensar en muchos
de estos como factores bióticos factores
relacionados con otros seres vivos
alrededor los factores independientes de
la densidad tienden a ser factores
abióticos es decir no están relacionados
con los seres vivos uno de los factores
independientes de la densidad más
conocidos son
desastres naturales aquí tenemos una
imagen de un incendio forestal la
densidad de población de estos venados
puede que no se encuentre para nada
cerca del límite de la capacidad de
carga de su medio pero sin importar esto
el incendio podría matar a muchos
venados entre los desastres naturales
podemos tener las inundaciones los
tsunamis meteoritos que vengan del
espacio exterior como le sucedió a los
dinosaurios y que destruyen a gran parte
de las poblaciones con los factores
independientes podríamos tener a una
población en crecimiento que en
cualquier momento puede ser diezmada por
un desastre natural y quizá después del
desastre la población vuelve a crecer y
alcanza el límite de la capacidad de
carga de su región
estos factores independientes no están
relacionados con algún punto en esta
curva pueden ocurrir en cualquier
momento toda esta charla sobre la
capacidad de carga y los factores
dependientes de la densidad de población
aplica también a los seres humanos pues
somos una especie y estas ideas también
aplican a nosotros existe una capacidad
de carga natural para los ambientes en
donde nos encontramos un filósofo
científico llamado thomas malthus dijo
que la humanidad tiene un problema muy
serio ya que nuestra población está
creciendo exponencialmente por lo que
habrá una capacidad de carga para los
seres humanos y como los seres humanos
seguimos creciendo exponencialmente
llegaremos al límite de esa capacidad de
carga en el caso de los seres humanos
matos determinó en dicho límite tenemos
un vídeo de este límite denominado
límite maltusiano la hipótesis es que
una vez que superamos este límite o nos
aproximamos a él ocurrirán todo tipo de
crisis una vez que se llegue a esta
capacidad de carga no habrá comida
suficiente y probablemente habrá
hambruna o epidemias y mucho más así que
él aplica estas ideas a los factores
dependientes de la densidad de población
y nos dice que no será agradable para la
humanidad lo interesante es que la
humanidad ha encontrado en varias
ocasiones
y aumentar la capacidad de carga para
nosotros como especie y hemos podido
hacerlo gracias a la tecnología
encontrando formas de cultivar alimentos
más eficientemente y encontrando formas
de combatir enfermedades al igual que
mejorar el manejo de desechos así que es
una pregunta filosófica interesante de
pensar si la humanidad alguna vez
llegará a alcanzar este límite de
malthus o si seremos siempre capaces de
evadirlo con mejor tecnología o quizás
regulando nuestra propia población con
control de la natalidad o planeación
familiar o lo que sea necesario para
evitar llegar a dicho límite